there's a very interesting shift in the
second choices of voters for the 2020
Democratic presidential candidates that
now is starting to increase the calls
for Elizabeth Warren to drop out in
order to help Bernie Sanders overtake
Joe Biden and I want to talk about this
with you this is a conversation I'm just
the messenger here of the data and then
I will analyze the data to the best of
my ability I want to be clear and I know
people always write to me they say David
you don't have to do these dumb
disclaimers trust me I do I am not
calling for anyone to drop out I am NOT
saying it's Warren who should drop
instead of Bernie because she's a woman
either consciously or unconsciously I'm
just telling you this is something we've
been talking about for a while it's
complex it's multifaceted and I want to
give you the data as it is and then I
will react to it and then we can have a
conversation so let me set it up for you
right now according to most national
polls I think all really Joe Biden is in
first place
in the 2020 Democratic primary with
Bernie Sanders second place in most
polls Elizabeth Warren third in most
polls there are some polls where Bernie
and Warren are statistically tied some
in which Elizabeth Warren is ahead by
sometimes a point or so so if you look
at the numbers you see that if you add
Bernie's polling to Elizabeth Warren's
polling you get a number that is bigger
than Joe Biden's in this case if we look
at the morning consult poll from
September 2nd to 8th you see that Bernie
and Warren together have 37% - Joe
Biden's 33 okay so the idea that keeps
coming up and that's being discussed and
that people contact me about is listen
Bernie and Warren are the two strong
progressive candidates aren't they
taking votes away from each other
Bernie drops out his support goes to
Warren Warren / overtakes Joe Biden or
conversely if Elizabeth Warren drops out
her support goes to Bernie Sanders he
overtakes Joe Biden progressives win
okay
now up until now I've been saying the
data doesn't seem to confirm that
because in the polls I have been
looking at the top second choice for
Bernie Boat voters has been Biden and
the top second choice for Warren voters
has been Kamala Harris which might seem
surprising because ideologically it
doesn't make sense but along demographic
lines it does make more sense but people
have started sending the recent data
from once again this morning console
poll conducted up until two days ago
ending on September 8th saying David the
numbers have changed Warren voters now
are saying Bernie is their top second
choice it would put Bernie into the lead
if Elizabeth Warren were to drop out but
is this actually what the data says yes
and no let's actually look at it it is
indeed true that in the most recent
morning consult poll the top second
choice for Bernie voters is Joe Biden
and the top second choice of Warren
voters is now Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren voters are now saying more about
Bernie than any other candidate that
elicits if Elizabeth Warren were to drop
out or not be the candidate they would
prefer Bernie Sanders but let's do the
math if Elizabeth Warren were to leave
the race 24% of her support would go to
Bernie 21% would go to Joe Biden and 19%
would go to Kamala Harris and when you
actually look at the numbers if you
divide up Elizabeth Warren's 16
percentage points and consider that only
slightly more of her voters would go to
Bernie than Biden it actually wouldn't
put Bernie in the lead what Elizabeth
Warren dropping out would do on the
basis of second choices in this poll is
it would put Biden at 36% and Bernie at
25% and Kamala Harris at 10% it would
not put Bernie Sanders into the lead her
percentage points 16 percentage points
would go disproportionately a plurality
would go to Bernie Sanders but some
would go to Biden as well and it
wouldn't be enough to put Bernie in the
lead so does this invalidate the idea
that the progressive movement would have
something to gain
if either Bernie or Warren dropped out
no it's possible that at some point that
is a conversation that will have to be
had if the first few primaries don't
sort
out on its own I don't think that we
need now to start saying things like top
three candidates should bail now we've
been talking about listen if you're not
even polling 1% if you're not even
polling 2% six seven months into this
race if you're not even making it into
the debates what is your path to victory
but I believe that the conversation
about Bernie and Warren dropping out now
is premature now if we get past the Iowa
caucus and the New Hampshire primary and
we get into February March I forget
exactly what the schedule is but I'm
sort of estimating here and it does seem
as though bearing in mind the 15 percent
vesting threshold that many primaries
have and all of these other things that
Joe Biden is ultimately going to squeak
by because of the division of the
progressive movement between Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and the
second choice data starts to suggest
that one or the other would take the
lead over Biden if the other were to
drop out then we actually will have
something to talk about I think there is
a very good chance that support
consolidates between now and the first
handful of primaries and that ultimately
the system will sort this out and if the
progressive movement is the strongest
movement then it will win out but the
point is even this new poll does not
show that there is a clear path to
victory over Joe Biden if either Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren were to drop
out now you could still believe that for
intangible reasons that might be the
case for momentum reasons that might be
the case but the data don't actually
bear that out right now let me know what
you think I do want to hear from you
about this